عندما يمرضون ، أعني أنهم
كان عمر جدتك 87 عامًا وكان
جدك يبلغ من العمر 89 أو 90 عامًا. أعني في
كلتا الحالتين ،
عندما مرضوا ، لا بد أنك كنت
قلقًا للغاية
بشأنهم بالطبع لكنهم لم
يكونوا قلقين للغاية.  يعني هل
اعتقدوا أنهم سينجو من الموت لأن
الجد كان مصمماً
على بلوغ عيد ميلاده التسعين الذي
كان سيصادف التاسع عشر من كانون الثاني (يناير)
، وعندما مرضوا لأول مرة قالوا
إنهم أصيبوا بنزلات البرد
ثم جاءت نتيجة اختبارهم إيجابية لكنهم
كانوا مصممين للغاية  لقد
تحدثنا إليهم جميعًا عبر الهاتف
ووجهنا إليهم من
قبل وحتى بعد أن
ذهبوا في البداية إلى المستشفى لم
يتعثروا أبدًا ولم يبدوا أبدًا قلقًا أو
خوفًا
، لقد عقدوا العزم على التغلب عليه
ولم يكن لديهم شك في أذهانهم
أنهم لن يعودوا إلى المنزل للتعبئة
في رحلتهم السنوية إلى فلوريدا ،
لقد كانوا أكثر انزعاجًا لأن
رحلتهم ستتأخر لأنهم فقط
كانوا مصممين على القتال والتغلب
عليها وأنا لا أفعل  أعتقد حقًا أنهم
فكروا في أي وقت مضى في نتيجة أخرى
، ولا يزال لديهم عدة سنوات جيدة متبقية
، وكانوا مستعدين لعيشها ، لذا
أخبرنا جيسي فقط أهمية
لعائلتك من
فكرة أنهم ماتوا على بعد دقائق من
بعضهم البعض ويمسكون بأيديهم
جيدًا على ما أعتقد  هذا الشيء
الذي يمنح عائلتنا القليل من
العزاء
الذي تعرفه في موقف فظيع هو
حقيقة أن أحدهم لم يكن مضطرًا
لتحمل خسارة الآخر ،
فقد كانوا معًا كثيرًا في كل مكان
يسافرون حول العالم
وأمهم  قصة حب
يتعلمها العالم الآن عن
أم كيف يمكنك كتابة نهاية أفضل
لهم يؤلمنا لكن يمكننا أن نكون
أنانيين هنا ونريد إبقاء الناس
معنا
عندما أعتقد أن الممرضة على ضفاف
النهر كانت رائعة جدًا
ماريا سوير  لقد لخصت الأمر
جيدًا ، كان الجد هو الرجل المثالي
الذي سمح لجدته بالذهاب أولاً وتبعها
خلفها مباشرةً وكيف يمكنك وصفها بشكل أفضل
مما
تعرفه فقط نهاية رائعة  ز
لحياة رائعة وزواج مذهل